كشفت دراسه امريكيه مشاهدينا حديثه ضروره
اخذ الموظفين قيلوله لمده عشر دقائق يا
ريت طبعا مؤكده ان تلك العاده من شانها
زياده القدره على الابداع البحث الذي اجري
في معهد ماسا تشوست للتكنولوجيا اوضح ان
هذه القيلوله الصغيره تشعل شراره ابداعيه
تساعد المخ على جمع افكاره من الذاكره
يستدعيها طبعا لفت الباحثون الى ان
التجارب اثبتت اصابه الموظف بتشتيت
ذهني في حال عدم حصوله على قيلوله مشيره
لايلا ان ذلك يؤدي حتما الى عدم القدره
على انجاز المهام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات